today let's talk about energy resources
you've probably already done something
today that used energy resources
even beginning from the moment you woke
up for me the beginning of my day
always starts with making tea i use
energy and every step of this process
my car uses oil when i drive to the
grocery store to get the tea
my stove uses natural gas when i boil
the water
and my water heater uses coal sourced
electricity
when i wash my mug in hot water
afterwards we use
energy constantly in our daily lives
since the first law of thermodynamics
states that energy cannot be created nor
destroyed
where does it all come from and will we
have enough
when we talk about energy resources we
could split it up into two groups
renewable energy and non-renewable
energy
i can always remember what renewable
resources are because the prefix re
means again and the root new refers to
the origin of the energy source
so renewable energy sources are the
sources that we can use again and again
and are quickly restored by natural
processes
renewable fuel sources include sunlight
wind
moving water biomass from fast-growing
plants and geothermal heat from the
earth
the lifespan of renewable resources
looks like a circle
we can use them and then we can use them
again without worrying about them
running out
non-renewable energy sources on the
other hand are sources that exist in a
fixed amount
and cannot be easily replaced these
energy sources must be extracted from
the earth
and they include things like nuclear
fuel
and fossil fuels which are things like
coal
oil and natural gas fossil fuels
performed in the geologic past
from the remains of ancient organisms
plants and animals that died
millions of years ago became buried in
the soil
partially decomposed and were exposed to
a lot of heat
and pressure this heat and pressure
chemically rearranged the energy
contained within their bodies
into the fossil fuels we use today
because they take
so long to form we have a finite amount
of non-renewable resources in the earth
right now
the lifespan for fossil fuels is a
broken loop
a one-way ticket first the fossil fuel
is found
then it has to be extracted extracting
fossil fuels can involve destructive
mining processes that can pollute
surrounding habitats
it then has to be transported to
wherever it will be used
and using fossil fuels means burning
them
which releases greenhouse gases and
other pollutants into the atmosphere
also it can take energy to refine and
process some types of fossil fuels so
that they're more helpful to us
like turning crude oil into petroleum
gas diesel and jet fuel and burning the
fossil fuels
transforms that energy into a less
organized form of energy
like heat and ash not all fossil fuels
are the same
and this is because different kinds of
organic material were heated and
compressed in different ways
creating different kinds of fossil fuels
one of these kinds of fossil fuels
is petroleum the word petroleum comes
from the latin word for rock
petra and the latin word for oil oleum
this makes sense
because it's an oily substance that's
found in reservoirs trapped in rock
humans have been using oil for a very
long time
early civilizations found it bubbling up
from the ground at natural wells
the oil they saw coming straight out of
the earth is called crude oil
or crude petroleum which means that it
is unrefined
and unprocessed crude oil was probably
one of the ingredients
in greek fire which was a flame throwing
weapon that the byzantines would fling
at their enemies
today we refined crude oil into many
products like gasoline
and diesel for vehicles kerosene for
heating
and asphalt for road construction it's
also used to make plastics
and synthetic fabrics another type of
fossil fuel
is coal which we mostly burn to make
electricity
but it can also be used for heating and
cooking
it's a solid shiny black flammable rock
which is mostly formed from the carbon
remains of fossilized plants
like moss over thousands of years
plant material transforms into a
carbon-rich compound called
peat and then with some pressure it
becomes soft coal
which is called lignite and then with
more pressure it becomes bituminous coal
and then finally it becomes a hard coal
called anthracite
the longer the plant remains are put
under pressure the more energy dense it
becomes
so if you burned anthracite you would
get a lot more energy than if you burned
peat
burning coal releases carbon dioxide
sulfur dioxide
nitrogen oxides and other gases into the
air
so coal is one of the dirtiest fossil
fuels
the cleanest burning fossil fuel is
natural gas
meaning that it emits the least amount
of carbon dioxide or other air
pollutants
this is not the same type of gas as we
put into our vehicles
that type comes from petroleum instead
natural gas
is mostly used for generating
electricity heating homes
and cooking food your oven furnace
water heater dryer or grill all might
run on natural gas
natural gas is a naturally occurring
mixture of gases
and it's mostly made up of methane
ethane propane
and butane the gas is colorless
and odorless so natural gas companies
often add a rotten egg smell to the fuel
to make leaks
easier to detect but even though we
can't see or smell natural gas
humans have been detecting it and using
it for centuries
there is evidence that more than 2 000
years ago people in china created bamboo
pipelines to transport the gas
so that they could use it to boil salt
water and separate out the salt
and today we still use pipelines to
transport gas across land
although they're no longer made out of
bamboo
another kind of non-renewable resource
is nuclear fuel
nuclear power plants don't burn fossil
fuels
instead they split uranium through
something called
nuclear fission just one kilogram of
uranium
can produce 24 million kilowatt hours of
energy
compare that with one kilogram of coal
which can produce eight kilowatt hours
of energy
in other words nuclear fission produces
a lot of energy
it also produces a lot of heat which we
mostly use to make electricity
also nuclear energy is known as a clean
energy
because the only greenhouse gas emission
is water vapor
which tends to cycle out of the
atmosphere faster than other greenhouse
gases
but the downside is the spent fuel is a
dangerous radioactive waste
and recycling the nuclear waste is
dangerous and expensive
petroleum coal natural gas and nuclear
fuel make up
85 percent of the world's energy
consumption but as our populations
and our energy needs grow it's becoming
more important to integrate renewable
resources
the sources that could be restored by
natural processes into our energy mix
i'm going to go make some tea now but
before i do here's something to think
about
what's something that you do in your day
that uses energy
does that energy come from fossil fuels
and if so
which one understanding how you get your
energy
is part of understanding what powers
your community your country
and the world